thank you
as we start winding down the year 2022
we've had our fair share of awesome
action anime and this list will be
counted down my top 10 favorite action
anime that started this year but don't
worry though I'll also be talking about
new anime this time no sequels and such
so you don't have any catching up to
starting off at number 10 is Rusty to
bisco
foreign
let's start off with something that we
don't hear people talk about often rust
eater bisco is one of those seasonal
action adventure series that tries to
hook you in with a unique and or
outlandish premise in this case it's all
about chronicling our protagonist's
journey through a world of rust as he
looks to find a cure for a plague that's
cursing the world it's got great world
building and the art is nice I think
it's not as much underrated as I view it
as a decent Adventure series that could
use some more polish still I really
liked if what it brings to the table and
the characters have their charms that
you might like it's also got some
battles to keep you watching while plot
twists get unveiled as our characters
learn more about the world overall Rusty
to bisco is a show that's carried by its
premise and production things look and
sound Top Notch and we've got some
intense battles ahead if you're up for a
dystopian Adventure like the good old
2000s this show could be the throwback
hit you'd love it
at number nine we look at skeleton light
in another world
[Music]
if you're out for an Issa guy from this
year though I'd seriously consider
checking out skeleton night in another
world the title may seem either plain or
edgy depending on who you are but it's
got a unique comfy feel that you don't
see from action it's a guy too often
I've seen people compare it to Overlord
but besides having overpowered skeleton
protagonists I think skeleton Knight
chooses to take a different approach
with the character arcs of their
protagonist the more traditional one if
you like that doesn't mean that the show
is shallow or anything like that for all
we know the world of skeletonite is
downright Wicked and we see the usual
anti-royalty themes a lot of isakai seem
to espouse it's a theme that I can't
help but appreciate no matter how often
it's been done in the genre and if the
story isn't enough to satisfy you
perhaps the visual and sound direction
will character designs look pretty cool
too it's a casual issakai that doesn't
exactly bring anything super
revolutionary to the table that doesn't
mean you can't find something to like
about it it's got some great fights a
likable cast of characters and nice art
and music do be aware though of some
sexual scenes that could cause
controversy however
I know everyone's excited to see more
anime recommendations but what's
watching anime without some handy sweets
by your side today's sponsors have got
you covered on that end introducing
Tokyo treat and sakurako Tokyo treat and
sakurako are a Duo of subscription boxes
that aim to share Japanese culture and
invite everyone to experience Japan
right in the comfort of their own homes
Tokyo tree being one that focuses more
on the latest and limited edition
exclusive seasonal snacks we'll be
providing a genuinely Japanese taste at
Christmas I bet you've never tasted
winter caramel Pocky before and the same
goes for donagiri Christmas corn chips
with a Tokyo tree subscription you can
have these snacks and more in this
month's Santa snack Fest box on the
other side then we have a sakurako the
box that features more of the
traditional Artisan side of Japan you do
get the best of the dojigi prefecture
thanks to their tying with the local
government and if like me you've never
been to the place before you can still
taste the best of what they have to
offer like these strawberry tiramisu
biscuits oh and did I tell you that
sakurako also provides some of the
prettiest kitchen wear and tee for this
month we'll be getting full of Shiki a
wrapping cloth we'll be taking things a
step further and introducing a free
ticket to Japan giveaway for December
don't forget to use my code vidi to get
five dollars off your first box and a
chance to experience Japan in person
it's a chance of a lifetime and it will
be a complete waste not to give it a
shot check the links below to know more
and I wish you luck in winning that
super special prize we have a movie up
next and it's bubble
[Music]
foreign
classical literature being the
inspiration for animes nothing new but
did anyone really expect to see a movie
that's inspired by The Little Mermaid as
in the original tragic version of that
yet here we are with bubble a movie that
dazzles us with astounding visuals that
give life to its symbolic world like a
lot of anime films bubble has that
magical Aura all throughout one that
wonderfully meshes with the art that
Harkens back to the shinkai films we've
come to love the story at first glance
seems like a typical Boy Meets Girl
story that we've seen a lot of times but
without giving spoilers I'd say that it
adds more to their usual Trope one thing
it has over a lot of other anime movies
is how well it does immersion a lot of
anime films cheat immersion through
rotoscoping visuals and all of that but
bubble manages to keep the audience
immersed in the fast pace of its action
sequences without being too overwhelming
a decent story backed by stunning
visuals and an amazing soundtrack but
was a treat for anyone looking to pick
up a new anime film action feels more
like a secondary genre compared to the
exploration and sci-fi in my opinion but
it's good enough in all counts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number seven
um
in contrast to the chill yet heroic
atmosphere skeletonite tries to impose
for a first impression Eminence in
shadow goes a different direction from
the get-go you see that it goes all in
on the chunibio side of things both
figuratively and literally you've got
Kirito XP here leading the charge from
the shadows and supporting him is a
harem of pretty and badass action girls
it's the usual stuff that you'd often
find in people's guilty pleasure lists
stuff that I unironically enjoy a lot
something like say arifureta in terms of
demographic it's got a lot going for it
in terms of the entertaining Factor
although it heavily caters to a specific
Niche or demographic still I think it's
worth a try if you're up for one of
these power fantasies it Embraces its
ridiculous nature while interweaving a
serious overtone and plot to complement
it it does take a while to rev up
because of the long Exposition dump in
the first few episodes for some reason
but when it found its footing it's a
show I thoroughly enjoyed it helps that
the art help gets the core factor of the
show across as well but if you're up for
something more generalist that you can
have a lot of fun with licorice recoil
is here
oh
I admit it before the season aired I
didn't think much of licorice recall
cute girls with guns on Special Ops I've
seen a lot of those already and it's not
particularly in my genre of Interest
however watching licorice recall
immediately made me think that I'm in
for something special and it's not in
the story or the setting being super
unique or memorable or anything like
that it's all in the execution people
may flock to licorice recall for the
guns and the queue but I think that the
strongest aspect this anime has going
for it is in its character Dynamics and
growth the main cast's colorful
personality shines through in their
interactions and even the antagonists
are cool and have depth you can really
feel the Chemistry Between the
characters of licorice recoil and that
enhances the show by a lot suddenly a
rescue up gets more emotional Stakes for
you suddenly a rage moment carries more
gravity and you get hooked to watching
the series always curious about what
fate awaits the characters it's the
emotional pull that's the Boon of
licorice recoil however that's not to
say that we should forget the amazingly
choreographed gunfights and action
sequences those things get really tense
at Key moments
foreign
[Music]
looks amazing and all and I'm happy with
it but you know what makes me happier
seeing the likes and subscriber numbers
increase so if you're enjoying the video
make sure to show your appreciation by
doing the two next in line is Gundam
witch from Mercury
[Music]
with Mecca as a genre taking more and
more Innovations and added gimmicks to
keep up with the modern anime scene of
trying to stand out it's no surprise
that Gundam would be the next franchise
to take that leap which from Mercury
decided to take the franchise to a place
I never expected it would go to half a
decade ago the whole Academy setting
with the jewels and of course you rebate
what I like about witch from Mercury
however is despite all the whole
modernization slash Innovation thing we
never lose too much focus on what I feel
was the franchise's main appeal the
mecca the mobile suits look as good as
ever and The Jewels have been
entertaining scuffles so far weaving the
fun of robot battles surprisingly
tactical and creative ones of that too
with animation that's surprisingly
top-notch then again it is Gundam so
what else did we expect which from
Mercury looks to be a new launching pad
for the franchise to recapture its Glory
Days aiming to pull from both new fans
and Veterans it's a serviceable one at
that too I don't think that the Glory
Days will ever come back in terms of
popularity but Gundam is here to stay
and evolve along with the times
cocoa
fourth place in my rankings is spy
family
my family really is something special
and I'd say that the show came up big
but not in the way I first expected it
as a non-reader of the manga back then
sure it's got its thrilling action
sequences that qualify it for this list
but I feel is the strongest part of spy
family is in its character Dynamics much
like what I said about licorice recoil
the entire main cast is just so likable
spy family also upset by providing a
comedic undertone to the character
interactions these people just seem like
people you'd want to be with and the
trials the forgers go through can be
both funny and wholesome it's a
legitimately heartwarming tale of family
something that you just don't expect to
see out of modern anime it's a breath of
fresh air from what we've come to expect
which explains its popularity so if
you're up for a treat to watch with your
family this is the 2022 anime for you
foreign
[Music]
for me is cyberpunk Edge runners
cyberpunk was a common genre in anime
but we haven't seen much of it lately
yet there's stuff like ghosts in the
Shell but how often do those come out
much less be picked by the mainstream
public then came cyberpunk Edge Runners
and the community went wild cyberpunk
Edge one has broke all my expectations
when I saw it I saw it as probably a
middle of the road nice show to watch
basically a glorified promotion material
for the gaming franchise but I came out
pleasantly surprised to have seen a show
that presents some strong and relatable
themes all under the guise of the Sci-Fi
and the explosions the best part of it
is how it engages the viewers early with
how cool it looks before pulling the
revelations the world the technology and
the action everything looks awesome and
hype then it pulls the curtain and
reveals some twists that make a second
guess on Life Choices and perceptions
right around episode 6 triggers also
Manning the wheels so seasoned fans will
probably know what else to expect
overall a surprisingly good video game
adaptation full of action and relevant
themes but I think I should be cutting
that surprisingly soon game adaptations
have been getting better and better
these days
in second place I pick summertime render
in a nutshell summertime render is a
time blue Thriller that has our hero
shinpei uncovering the Mysteries behind
Shadows that began appearing in an
island when things start connecting to
human deaths and a Sinister Supernatural
Force enveloping the island that's when
we know we're in for a ride summertime
render is the show in this list that I
feel the most satisfied watching the
mystery part of the series has done so
well you left anticipating the episodes
after coming up with theories left and
right and as each episode unfolds you
start seeing the bigger picture and how
well the writing is it also does a great
job in adding Stakes to the time loot
mechanic to keep the suspense up instead
of giving the protagonist a cheat code
the pacing is on point the action's on
point and it's a show that has such a
strong foundation in terms of its plot
summertime render has a serious case of
being 2020s anime of the year
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
of course we end with the most hyped new
title of 2022 period honestly speaking I
could interchange this placement with
summertime render well summertime render
envelops its narrative with mystery and
gets you to think and piece the clues
together chainsaw man goes Full Throttle
with the high octane action and the
Carnage gets animated in such a glorious
manner you know the studio just gets
their priorities straight the title has
been given much deserved love from both
the studio and the fan base chainsaw man
is an exhilarating ride and while it's
easy to brush it off is a simple and
just action and brutality isn't that the
point here chainsaw man is a title that
thrives on the Simplicity while
deconstructing some of the usual tropes
that we've come to expect out of a jump
title yeah it is a jump title and it's
probably the one you'd want to watch the
most if you're in it for the fighting
and the unrelenting nature of R-rated
action titles
now how does your top 10 list compare to
mine if you've got something to comment
on head down to the comment section and
share your thoughts or you can drop by
the Channel's Discord or other social
media thank you for watching and I hope
you had a good time if you found
something new to watch thanks to this
list then do tell me because that would
definitely make my day hoping to see you
next time